m
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
un
an dans la plus belle ville du monde
quatre saisons au fil de l'eau au
printemps rencontre avec francesco un
conte vénitien pas tout à fait comme les
autres dimanche pour la vogalonga il n'y
aura que des bateaux à rames et des
milliers de rameurs la vogalonga la plus
grande course du printemps 32 km à
travers la lagune
en été nous serons au balcon des plus
beaux palais du grand canal vers les
fenêtres plants de café le matin en
feuilletant le grand canal et tous les
bateaux qui commence à bouger c'est
l'autoroute le matin
au lido avec alain nous découvriront les
coulisses de la mostra le
plus glamour des festivals de cinéma
c'est toujours comme ça
en automne on est
nous partirons à la découverte des
endroits les plus secrets de la lagune
[Musique]
on va mettre tout ça dans notre estomac
maintenant
novembre celle acqua alta notamment tu
là
et le dernier maître verrier de l'île de
murano
en hiver c'est évidemment le temps du
carnaval
[Musique]
francesco dame au sto est né à venise il
y a un peu plus de 50 ans
c'est ma ville
ça ça paraît incroyable mais c'est comme
ça
entre les dames au sto et venise c'est
une très vieille histoire de famille au
palais que vous voyez là en restauration
appartenait à notre famille il n'est
plus à nous parce que un de mes ancêtres
la donner en héritage au neveu de sa
deuxième femme c'était au xviie siècle
les dames où ce taux ont donc dû
déménager sur un canal mineurs
c'est toujours ici qu'on se croise ouais
mais toi tu es toujours au travail
[Rires]
ce matin au marché du rialto les étals
sent bon le printemps
ça ce sont des artichauts vraiment tout
petit ils sont typiques de venise en les
exporte dans le monde entier c'est
excellent regarde les plus de son petit
et plus sont donc
à venise il n'y a pas de supermarché
quand même cru c'est vraiment délicieux
tous les légumes viennent de lille ii
saint-erasme
regarde tout ce qu'il ya là vient mon
potager à trois kilomètres d'ici il ya
juste un canal de la lagune a traversé
avec seulement 60 mille habitants venise
est un gros village
où les vénitiens passent leur temps à se
croiser
comment tu vas un mois va tout va bien
aller à la prochaine
il fait tellement bon que je vais
prendre ma journée aujourd'hui
depuis quatre siècles les dames au sto
ont la même adresse
[Musique]
et ça c'est ma maison
et
ici à part l'électricité rien n'a changé
oui
avant dans les palais c'était comme une
communauté à l'étagé il y avait la
maison mais les bureaux et dans le hall
on stocker les marchandises
mon bureau est toujours la lune y avoir
c'est un peu le foutoir
architectes écrivains
francesco est un touche à tout dans le
plus pur esprit de la renaissance
alors quand elle ou moi pour retrouver
des choses il faut que je les vois ça je
ne vois pas c'est qu'elles sont perdus
mais comme l'avait fait
comme tous les vénitiens
francesco n'a jamais eu de voiture
mais ils gardent religieusement son
premier bateau celui qu'il a reçues pour
ses 18 ans
quelquefois quand ils libres ils gardent
leurs marges dans le canal et là tu est
bloquée et tu attends tu as tu en es tu
siffles ça ne sert à rien
une seule fois dans l'année venise ce
vide totalement de ces milliers de
vedettes à moteur
c'est l'événement du printemps
alors là c'est le bassin de saint marc
le palais des doges a salute and san
giorgio et dimanche pour la vogalonga il
n'y aura que des bateaux à rames et des
milliers de rameurs
ce n'est pas une course mais tout le
monde veut aller le plus vite possible
on ne fait pas de quartier
mathieu le français et sam le
californien seront dimanche sur la ligne
de départ
on s'entraîne pour remuscler un petit
peu ce qui va bien parce que là sur la
lagune dans les canaux c'est très stable
y'a pas de soucis mais dans la lagune il
ya des vagues donc il faut gérer son
équilibre lui les surfeurs en californie
non ce n'est pas trop un problème pour
lui
c'est participent chaque année pour moi
c'est devenu une tradition c'est ça qui
me lie à venise
mathieu est pilote de ligne il vit à
venise depuis deux ans
[Musique]
évidemment
la france canal où le prochain comme tu
veux
c'est toi le capitaine
des reds tel capitaine moi je suis le
botteur way
et donc à gauche c'est le rialto
et comme il fait beau il ya toutes les
banderoles qui sont sortis
de nos visites en quoi la team étirement
au poulet il a faim on va s'arrêter
manger quelque chose
qui n'a pas mangé encore de piller ce
matin
sur les quais du riz à la
séance de photo à l'italienne
karamé
sam et mathieu n'ont plus que deux jours
d'entraînement avant la course
j'espère vraiment qu'il va pas pleuvoir
à venise au printemps les bourrasques
viennent du large de l'adriatique
mathieu et sa maintiennent tout de même
leur inscription à la course
nous autorise jusqu'à 1700 bateau en
fait
c'est le maximum autorisé en fait donc
là a priori vu qu'il reste encore des
posters tout le monde doit pas être
encore de la place
il reste encore une heure
une signature et le dossard numéro 3 139
est officiellement enregistrés
on est prêt à aller on sera prêts
l'aller est ce qu'on peut stresser
un conseil éclairé
car en mai venise change de ciel en
quelques minutes
francesco emmène ses enfants à la fête
de l'école tu vois c'est la fête du
printemps
chaque printemps
les parents d'élèves et les
institutrices organise une kermesse
bucolique
on a de la chance c'est un des soldes
jardin qui est resté par la nappe à
bouffer mon histoire c'était un ancien
hôpital pour les enfants
[Applaudissements]
bon ben voilà on a la possibilité
d'utiliser
5 0 est la seule école de lille avec un
jardin le cadre idéal pour célébrer le
retour des beaux jours
on apprend de bâton régulièrement on
sort toute la journée dehors des jeunes
francesco et son fils pier angelo
doivent s'absenter
aia
allez
[Applaudissements]
ils vont retrouver les gondoliers de
lansana
une association qui restaure les vieille
barque vénitienne
comment vous allez
oui on est prêts on a tous peur pour
demain alors
la halle au jazz ep paulo sont des amis
d'enfance
francesco va ramer sur leur bon donne
[Musique]
dans leur hangar à bateaux
il accumule un incroyable le bric à brac
c'est ici que chaque année il prépare la
vogua longue
allée à la grande aventure
parmesan saucisson et prosecco pas
vraiment un menu de galleri
lui c'est le premier homme à bord c'est
lui qui donne le rythme
[Musique]
encore
créé il y à 40 ans pour célébrer l'art
de ramer à la vénitienne
debout face à la proue le succès de la
vogalonga est chaque année plus
important
on y vient du monde entier
[Musique]
sur sa terrasse le quai ligny le plus
ancien club nautique de venise reçoit
polenta géante
c'est ici que mathieu sam compte appris
à ramer à la vénitienne
et comment ça va on se retrouve ici
chaque année
c'est vraiment une course à l'italienne
ici tout le monde reçoit un prix sauf
celui qui arrive le premier
ce soir francesco accompagne pierangelo
à 14 ans et sa première vogalonga
il doit normalement ramé sur l'a10
d'automne
24 mètres de long la plus grande
gondoles de venise
mais les prévisions météo vont
bouleverser leurs projets non ça sera
pas la tempête mais il y aura une pluie
battante et ils y arrivent devant
non le vent c'est sûr qu'il y en aura
alors les plus jeunes ne pourront pas
ramer oui parce que soit on fait comme
ça soit la gondole ne partent pas
grosse déception
l'a10 de tonna partira sans pierangelo
dimanche matin grand canal
malgré le mauvais temps le moral reste
bon sur la gondole de francesco
je crois que ça va être une belle
journée
on est tous pas se battre pour gagner
malgré le temps
sur le bassin de saint marc mille huit
cents bateaux attendent le départ c'est
un record
[Musique]
il nous reste plus que numérique
car
[Musique]
au coup de canon
c'est parti pour 32 km à travers la
lagune
propulsé par c10 hui rameurs l'a10
d'automne distance très vite ça mais
mathieu
première difficulté la sortie du bassin
de saint marc
le problème c'est qu'il ya une courbe à
angle droit
beaucoup de courant elle est très
étroite et en plus tous les bateaux se
retrouvent au même endroit
tout le monde accélère pour conserver la
meilleure trajectoire
pendant la course c'est chacun pour soi
[Musique]
pas de pitié pour les naufragés
dragon boat chinois
prototype à condition qu'ils soient
arabes tous les types de bateaux peuvent
participer
dès la sortie du chenal
les conditions se détériorent rapidement
[Musique]
le vent soufflait de face
c'est la partie la plus difficile de
l'itinéraire
[Musique]
après quatre heures d'efforts les canaux
offre enfin leur refuge
[Applaudissements]
à venise au printemps il suffit parfois
de passer un pont
[Applaudissements]
pour que le miracle se produise
[Musique]
maintenant on va pouvoir déboucher le
procès quand on l'a bien mérité
aujourd'hui la ram est à l'honneur
[Applaudissements]
et chaque équipage est tour à tour
récompensés
[Musique]
et jean dominique
vidal georges français danois helle mon
client
chacun reçoit son certificat
pendant 24 heures venise n'aura entendu
aucun bruit de moteur
[Musique]
l'été se venise est une fourmilière
elle accueille cent mille touristes par
jour
[Musique]
francesco en profite pour prendre le
large de bombay
pas faux avec deux de ses enfants il
part passé la soirée loin de la foule
elle dit
en kit venise et on se dirige vers le
nord de la lagune
et papa qu'est ce qu'on va manger sur
l'île ce soir
je sais pas de crackers
[Musique]
mazères beto n'est qu'à 6 km à vol
d'oiseau de venise mais c'est un autre
monde
ici on commence une autre via
le week end tout le monde se retrouve
c'est comme une grande famille
sur l'île tout le monde se connaît
ce soir on fait une petite fête pour mes
filles on se voit vers 4 heures
tu vas conviennent à quelle heure là
les gens arrivent vers 4h mais la fête
commencera que vers 19 heures
c'est une soirée alors formidable tout à
l'heure alors
max et le voisin immédiat de francesco
mazères béto c'est un peu le paradis
surtout pour les plus jeunes
alors là mais la théorie tu veux
conduire maintenant
aller tourner à gauche
nom dans le côté d'ivoire
chaque maison possède son pompon avait
bel accueil
à mazères béto il n'y a que des cabanes
de pêcheurs dako zahui
oulala il ya des grillons partout
sur l'île il n'y a pas d'eau courante ni
d'électricité
mais la vue voix est imprenable les
mains
là bas au fond il y à tous les grands
filets de pêcheurs
toutes les structures sont construction
pilotis d'elecam souffre à lafitte
totalement préservée li na pas de
clôture à caen pour passer d'une maison
à l'autre il suffit de suivre le chemin
pour avant
les stats et à soupe n'était c'est
vraiment la meilleure saison pour faire
des fêtes
pour profiter de la lagune
c'est le meilleur moment
regarde les gens se retrouvent
il ya de la musique
la dolce vita à la vénitienne
[Musique]
zèle
elena fête avec ses amis son 25e
anniversaire
regardez la vue est magnifique on a
installé des bancs et des chaises là bas
pour que tout le monde en profite
la sérénissime
sur 180° qu
on voit tout venise et la basse et san
marin
oui la coupole verglas base c'est le
campanile est ce un mal
au même moment
sur le bassin de saint marc
des buts une autre fête
ah oui c'est magnifique
c'est une partagent une communion à tout
le monde et sur les bateaux tout le
monde partage à sers moi c'est pour ça
c'est la plus belle fête de venise
passer une fête en plus on a un temps de
rêve pas un nuage
la fête du rédempteur au mois de juillet
célèbre tout simplement l'été la lagune
et le bonheur d'être vénitien
temps et il aucune ne semble en fait
mathieu et ses amis cherchent une place
pour jeter l'ancré
car à minuit ils vont assister au plus
grand feu d'artifice de l'année
à l'entrée du grand canal autour de la
pointe de la douane les embarcations
traditionnelles se sont toutes donné
rendez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le bateau c'est comme une maison si on
t'invite sur un bateau c'est comme si tu
entrer dans la maison de thé haute on
invite à dîner et puis tu passes d'une
barque à l'autre
on se connaît pas forcément mais on
discute on est tous ensemble on apprend
à se connaître on partage nos plats nos
vins
et tout d'un coup
il est déjà munich
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à la fin de l'été
venise fait le cinéma
c'est le rendez vous des stars et des
photographes alain à mon français
d'origine et vénitien d'adoption prépare
sa journée alain a deux passions venise
et la photo
on va reporter le grand canal jusqu'au
bassin saint marc
papa c'est du côté de san giorgio
maggiore on va finir comme envers le on
nous dit non
au lido commence aujourd'hui la mostra
le célèbre festival du cinéma vénitien
sur le chemin les yachts donne le ton
les stars du cinéma sont déjà là
le lido est une des rares îles de la
lagune où circulent des voitures
je vois qu'il ya des photographes qui
attendent
donc il est sûrement prévu une
conférence de presse à midi
donc je pense que c'est peu on peut très
bien avoir une arrivée de d'acteurs
serions 11h45
pour cette journée d'ouverture deux
superstars hollywoodiennes sont attendus
et pour une fois elles sont à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
georges que lui
et sandra bullock
le couple vient présenter gravity leur
dernier film à la mostra de venise
[Applaudissements]
alfonso cuaron
le metteur en scène les accueillent
et il n'est pas tout seul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est toujours comme ça avec cp ce soit
le public mais
lis les photographes
jouent le jeu puis c'est quand même la
star
sculpteur
dans l'impressionnante salle de presse
du palais des congrès
alain met tout de suite en ligne ses
photos
son blog est exclusivement dédié à
venise un coup de foudre un coup de
foudre il ya très longtemps et qui à
venir bouleverser ma vie et quand j'ai
découvert venise c'est ce que de penser
un jour bien salée et maintenant j'y vis
depuis six ans et
j'espère y rester un peu plus longtemps
bossé pour voir toujours
tenue de soirée ce soir pour francesco
et sa femme jane
ciao
mon dieu quelle agitation
c'est un peu intimidante
cette année c'est la 70e édition de la
mostra
les dames au sto ont été invités à la
première
non
les photographes prennent les premiers
place de chaque côté du tapis rouge
alain est aux premières loges
[Musique]
le scénario de la soirée est
parfaitement tôt
arrive d'abord les second rôles ils ne
font que passer
ensuite les membres du jury
regain d'intérêt d'autant que cette
année
virginie ledoyen en fait partie
[Musique]
puis catégorie à part les belles d'un
soir
[Musique]
à tour de rôle
elle s'enflamme le tapis rouge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin c'est le bouquet final
les superstars
[Musique]
georges que ni entre dans l'arène
en quelques minutes il va signer plus de
500 autographes
à metz
et le show continue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le film remportera sept oscars à
hollywood quelques mois plus tard
[Applaudissements]
sandra bullock s'occupe des photographes
pendant que change
retourne auprès de ses fans
pourquoi on nous parle le temps que
passe
peux rester ici ça fait presque 20
minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fin du spectacle
fait
magnifique semaine
à la vas finir la soirée
sur un petit nuage
[Musique]
oh
à
la fin du mois d'août venise renoue avec
son passé
et comme souvent l'action se passe le
long du grand canal
tél
tout le monde attend ce jour si vous
êtes vénitien et que vous avez une
grande maison vous recevez les invités
pour assister au spectacle
mon palais ne donne pas sur le grand
canal alors moi je suis habité dans un
autre palais pour voir mon fils
pierangelo qui naviguent aujourd'hui
le pas l'idée grimani comme tous les
palais vénitien à un accès sur la rue à
un autre sur l'eau
là c'est la porte d'eau c'est vraiment
une atmosphère typiquement vénitienne
ali plage noble
[Applaudissements]
les premiers invités sont déjà
je pensais
ce genre d'événement tu invites toutes
les années
c'est un moment où l'on célèbre venise
et madame est une merveilleuse maîtresse
de maison
tu as deux invités de toutes les
nationalités
des français des anglais
eh ben ça c'était venise à voir
quant à cette équipe de nice très
cosmopolite autres et
si dans cette maison on essaye à un
corps d'avoir plein de gens qui vient
petit peu de
3d doge de venise
étaient des grilles manille
c'est l'une des plus illustres familles
de venise
les balcon du palais donne directement
sur le grand canal
vous avez les palets moting blanc
byron a buté et après enfantine enfin
vous avez tous les grands pas les
cheveux ni ça c'est le côté du grand
canal peut-être le put
enfin je sais pas il n'est pas le plus
beau moment il ya beaucoup de talent et
un tout petit boulot qui sont vraiment
beau
le premier dimanche de septembre
c'est la régate historique
[Musique]
au 14ème siècle la république vénitienne
est à son apogée
c'est la plus grande puissance
économique de la méditerranée
en l'honneur de cet âge d'or la
sérénissime parade tout l'après midi
mais ce que tout le monde attend
vraiment
c'est cela
ce sont les formule 1 de la lagune
entre les deux meilleures équipes la
rivalité est légendaire ils finissent
chaque année au coude à coude
les frais en ligne auto de saint-erasme
ils sont magnifiques
[Applaudissements]
et comme chaque année les perdants se
cherche des excuses
ils se plaignent parce qu'ils disent
qu'ils ont été bousculés et les
troisièmes aussi conteste
la brouille durera douze mois jusqu'à
l'été prochain
[Applaudissements]
a venise les lumières d'automne sont
légendaires
[Applaudissements]
regardez ces reflets sur l'eau c'est
magnifique
l'hiver il y a moins d'air et la lumière
est plus dur plus forte
en automne c'est plus pur regarde c'est
tellement pur que l'on voit toutes les
montagnes et la neige aussi hu
le massif des dolomites cours du piémont
jusqu'à venise
tu vois
francesco a rendez vous avec des
pêcheurs de bure à nos relais
la lagune compte une trentaine d'îles
bur anneaux est facilement
reconnaissable
son clocher est sérieusement bancal
à venise toutes les maisons sont
construites sur pilotis
des pieux enfoncés dans la vase et
quelquefois la base est moins dense et
du coup les fondations bouge
dure à nos est une île de dentellière et
de pêcheurs
et en octobre
ils sont très occupés
regardez ce sens là voilà les pêcheurs
de moins qu est bondée
les mots etc et c'est un don de la
nature
des petits crabes verts qui muent en
automne
chaque jour ils sont triés pour ne
garder que les mous
les vénitiens en raffolent
ça fait des centaines d'années que vous
faites ça non
comment vous les cuisiner avec de
l'huile d'olive ou de l'huile végétale
non à l'huile végétale allant des débats
sur le marché les mots et qui va le plus
de 50 euros le kilo
mais aujourd'hui
c'est un cadeau
formidable
maintenant on va mettre tout ça dans
notre vente
novembre c'est le mois des grandes
marées
l'adriatique s'invite dans la lagune
celle acqua alta
mon temps
mais dès qu'elle se termine ici nous
fait si je continue je tombe dans le
grand canal
et un accident est vite arrivé
j'en ai vu un tombé d'un coup le faisais
des photos il marche en arrière et plus
[Rires]
la samare il y à 60 centimètres d'eau
toute l'esplanade est inondée
le vent du large empêche tout se retirer
et les touristes forcément doivent
s'adapter
vous vous rendez compte c'est notre
anniversaire de mariage et on se rend
dans un grand restaurant
et regardez c'est la tempête tout est
inondé ma femme et moi ressemble à
kermit la grenouille
chaque automne
venise est submergé plus d'une douzaine
de fois
allez on va prendre un café à la cua
halte à
mon nom
la cuenta en 66 elle est montée jusqu'à
à peu près jusqu'ici
incroyable mais qu'est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on fasse il faut continuer à
vivre alors on fait comme d'habitude
muriel balenci et parisienne
l'aqua alta aujourd'hui la un peu prise
par surprise
[Musique]
muriel travail à murano l'île des
verriers
ce matin elle va retrouver son compagnon
dans l'un des ateliers les plus anciens
de l'île à la havane sur la lagune en
fait et le fait est que c'est une des
zones où les maisons sont les plus
hautes parce qu'après lui manque un pont
qu'une habitation qui arrêtent l'arrivée
de l'eau directement dans la liga
à murano l'on travaille le verre depuis
le moyen-âge
giovanni est sans doute le maître
verrier le plus doué de sa génération
il a commencé à l'âge de 12 ans
c'est juste et adolescents
tu peux pas exprimer ce sont des mots
qui t'a bien naturel aussi naturel avec
la matière pour moi oui non
non pour faire les plus sûrs comme ça
pour la gravité dont la gravité avec le
centre rotateurs le bateau lyon compte
accord start war
aussi incroyable que cela paraisse dans
cet exercice giovanni n'a jamais cassé
un barrage
toutes ces pièces sont uniques
tout ce que tu rêves et moi je moi je
et justement
muriel à m
alors ça en fait ce sont les perles que
j'ai
réalisés à l'atelier et c'est le projet
que qu'on est en train de faire avec
giovanni
l'objectif est de créer un flacon à
parfum
inédit
ok
[Musique]
pour faire le bouchon du flacon giovanni
van loyers dans du cristal pur la perle
de couleurs
un nouveau procédé
qui
chauffée à plus de 1000 degrés la paire
le fonds et ses dires
je peux le faire hexagonal mais si c'est
trop petit ça n'ira pas alors je préfère
le faire eux valent
e
en ajoutant du cristal en fusion
giovanni fini par obtenir exactement ce
qu'il souhaite
en l'insérant dans le transparent on
distingue toutes les couleurs que moi
j'ai inséré au départ dans ma sphère on
distinguait pas sur le petit modèle
on va avec h et
demain giovanni façonnera le flacon
[Musique]
avec la marée descendante
la cua alta se retire
libé revenir
et le grand canal retrouve son nom
[Musique]
alain monde a été invité par francesco
pour déguster les crabes verts
pour accéder à la cuisine il faut
traverser le palais
[Applaudissements]
c'est une des plus belles salles
le porter go le grand hall du ballet
la
elvis d'un mostow un ancêtre de
francesco qui au xvème siècle a
découvert les îles du cap vert
à laitages
tout le monde se mette en cuisine
papa alès je sais faire
mais c'est pierangelo qui décide de
prendre les choses en main
c'est trop lourd est d'accord
une fois roulé dans la farine il suffit
de faire frire trois minutes
les crabes où se mange entier
un délice englouti en quelques secondes
[Musique]
février lors du carnaval a sonné ce
matin francesco va choisir son costume
je vais voir stefano nicolas aux assauts
de marc collat
stephano c'est un peu le pierre cardin
du carnaval de venise
bonjour à tous
stefano je sais qu'il est occupé mais
c'est vraiment le seul qui peut m'aider
le maître costumier est en pleine séance
d'essayage avec des clients américains
madame un souhait
incarner une comtesse du xviie siècle
j'en rêve depuis que j'ai 5 ans
et là ça y est je suis dans mon rêve
pour francesco c'est au premier étage là
c'est mon trésor tu peux faire ton choix
je peux c'est celui là le rouge
celui là il me plaît
quelle belle et offre
l'essai de la soie oui c'est de la soie
set j'ai une telle issue
après je te donnerai les chameaux
dans son atelier stefano conserve plus
de dix mille costumes
tous
sont faits sur mesure
c'est le costume officiel de la
colombine celle qui va descendre du
campanile
oui cette année tu vois on est sur les
tons plutôt vers caen s'est inspiré du
verre de murano le thème c'est la beauté
de la nature
il est magnifique
[Musique]
pour admirer le vol de l'ange ils sont
tous la
poudre et
masqués
coiffer
[Musique]
c'est la crème des carnavaliers
les puristes du costume historique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je le prends bien ce avec un petit pas
d'âne marking régit les unes vers les as
porte des chemises à jabot bien une
canne et bijoux et bijoux nous sommes à
venise dans des bijoux les militants
yves et bruno sont des fidèles ils n'ont
pas manqué un carnaval depuis dix ans
elle non plus ne rate jamais cette
journée d'ouverture sur la place sabiine
ils cherchent et ce n'est pas simple le
meilleur ongles pour la descente de lens
accroché
elle est partie
à midi pile
suspendu à un câble
chez mais la violence de caméras le
déjeuner
la plus jolie fille de l'année entame
son envie
c'est l on se pose en
qui officiellement donne le coup d'envoi
du carnaval
[Musique]
si venise a ses codes le carnaval à ses
rituels
chaque après midi de l'autre côté du
bassin de sa main le parvis de l'église
de san giorgio accueille les allégorique
vous attendent le coucher du soleil
parce que ça va donner des couleurs
magnifiques elle arrive à ça il ya que
les couleurs de boucher le soleil
effectivement avec le fond de la place
saint-marc est derrière le palais des
doges de campagne in
cas cela vaut
derrière leurs masques les allégorique
cultive le mystère
protègent leur identité
à l'opposé les historiques s'affiche à
visage découvert
oui je suis directrice de développement
sur de l'immobilier entreprise je
conçois des grands centres commerciaux
que rien à voir avec le carnaval de nice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marty le matin yves et bruno ont été
piratés tout l'après midi
oui il faut vous changez par jour un
général deux fois petit costume de jour
soit une petite fume c'est un costume
facile à vivre notamment comme
aujourd'hui gk donnerait une soirée un
conseil ne peut plus imposer un peu plus
grand qu'un terrain un peu plus fort
suivant le thème du
jambon de carnavaliers avec ses costumes
au fond là vous avez là une vingtaine de
costumes pour deux personnes
on a notamment des costumes
ecclésiastiques et cette année c'est la
première année alors je vous montrais
les petits chapeaux qui l'on avait
même petit chapeau tout simple petit
chapeau de don camillo bon un peu ce
tracé parce que c'est le carnaval
vous allez retrouver le même velours
rouge le même motif qu'on a vu sur la
mitre qui brodé par nous mêmes on a une
grosse deux ont fait nombre de riz
avec ça il y a
l'accessoire qui va avec la dame terre
et qui vivait sur la chasuble le petit
manteau préparant froid
est pour ce soir
ça ce sont des copies
copie de généraux l'ambiance assez la
copie-conforme va remonter le dit quand
il avec copie conforme
[Musique]
la métamorphose est saisissante
comme chaque soir yves et bruno vont
prendre un verre au café florian
le plus ancien salon de thé de venise
alors en général canadien c'est
l'habitude à venise en grande forme soit
du chocolat ils ont réparé la panne où
nous nous préférons le spritz une bonne
fondée en 1720 le florian est le point
de rendez vous incontournable des
carnavaliers
le décor parfait
pour un voyage dans le passé
doit on également
[Musique]
oh
dans son palais
[Musique]
le compte d'un mostow s'apprête à sortir
et
le carnaval c'est comme vivre une
deuxième vie
[Musique]
une vie cachée alors chacun sa vie comme
il le souhaite vraiment
[Musique]
vivre à un moment différent loin du
quotidien
et ça fait ce soir nous allons au bal du
doj
le bail du doj c'est la soirée la plus
prisée du carnaval de venise
les invités tous costumés
sont déposés sur le poteau d'un groupe
le palazzo pizza ni mort et d'un revit
ce soir les fastes du xviiie siècle
[Musique]
antonien est ici la grande prêtresse
dans les salons le dîner et écrivain
charge
m
alors que
le palais pizza ni moretto date du 15ème
siècle
ça c'est le salon historique
vous avez ici toute l'histoire du palais
de ces différents propriétaires
et ici vous avez d'autres portraits de
personnages historiques
le conte d'amo ce taux est à la table
d'honneur
entouré de convives
venus du monde entier
april dîner
pour le reste de la nuit suivez des
courtisanes
casanova farinelli et les chants
lyriques du xviiie siècle
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'aube
le grand canal s'éveille
un petit matin d'hiver
comme francesco les aime
c'est vraiment ma ville
je ne peux pas m'imaginer vivre sans
elle
même si quelquefois je dois partir je
sais que j'y reviens toujours
[Musique]